today i saw this tweet and it blew me
away i don't even like to say that word
i don't like to say that word but i'm so
concerned with other [ __ ] and and this
is this is the hypocrisy of the left
that that really rubs me the wrong way
so philip defranco
he's been
going after people who will not get the
vaccine saying all kinds of stuff and
then he made this fake apology today and
he said
um
i'm done trying to convince you guys
that's over i'm not gonna i'm just gonna
mock you for believing a bunch of face
grifter monetizing misinformation or
english over scientists using the most
recent and relevant info right basically
just laughing the folks and you know one
thing that's hilarious about folks on
left right the right folks they don't
even like to acknowledge a lot of
history when it comes to minorities but
left folks they claim right
riots come about blm comes about they're
like i understand why black folks are
mistrusting of the government
considering your history it makes sense
to me i understand why even if i don't
condone it sometimes they do condone it
but they understand it then this
pandemic comes wrong and they're like
you [ __ ] anti-veg why would you not
do you not know the history of
minorities and healthcare system in
america and in north america and the
world in general do not know what
they've done to those folks but i'm not
talking about this pandemic i'm talking
about medical treatments in general
minority communities have been
distrusting of the medical system for a
long time and very valid reasons if you
guys are aware of what happened tuskegee
and other places throughout this
continent right the way that experiments
were done on these folks the way that
the health care system mistreated them
misdiagnosed right there's a deep seated
mistrust between these communities and
science community as well as the health
community government in general you can
understand it when it's in relation to
cops
do you think [ __ ] like
lawyers you think they like court
systems
do you think they like any branch of the
government they see it as all extensions
of the same problem so it just makes me
laugh that you guys are ready to see the
nuance when it comes to things that
really don't affect you right
because what i'm a ride in milwaukee who
why would you give a [ __ ]
but now your money's being affected all
of a sudden the opinions and minorities
and their reasons for being distrustful
you don't give a [ __ ] about
and i'm saying as someone who's taken
the vaccine
yes you go what oh my god you're not
anti-i'm not but i'm not
and a lot of other people didn't still
took it it's okay not and this is the
problem with this conversation i'm [ __ ]
you guys if you forgive me either it's
either you're here
or you're there no michael jackson it's
black it's white
yeah yeah and we know it and i'm i'm
gonna forgive me bro today i'm mad oh i
could see that
man this is all man because it's the
hypocrisy
oh how could you be dead people yo did
you remember reading those headlines
where they were doing the vaccine trials
in africa how's the [ __ ] supposed to
feel i know right did you just break
your necklace out of nothing now your
necklace is mad my necklace is mad okay
so then why my [ __ ]
it's like it's like this right i cannot
stand i understand people are afraid i
understand people are concerned i
understand that a lot of you trust this
information and with good reason listen
i'm with you guys on that but what i
don't do is look at the people who are
hesitant who don't want it or have very
valid concerns and look at them and
immediately label somebody who's not
open-minded why are you talking then if
you don't think they're open-minded just
shut the [ __ ] up and stay in your corner
what you want to get on here virtue
signal and be like you guys are idiots
stop talking to them they're just in
your corner if you don't believe these
people you can communicate with them but
to think
that everyone who hasn't done it is this
unreasonable trump support you guys are
so misguided and this is why i don't buy
into a lot of liberal media when it
comes to like we're for minorities
you're not you're just there for them
when it's convenient you are not
actually interested in learning the
history and why this deep-rooted
mistrust exists why their turnout rates
are so low when it comes to voting why
their turnout rates are so low when it
comes to any kind of medical checkup you
don't know and you don't give a [ __ ] so
don't get up here and post your black
squares say all this [ __ ] about how
you support this or that but then when
it comes to what they're going through
you didn't even want to do a modicum of
research you want to label them a piece
of [ __ ] you want to say you want to kill
your neighbors you don't give a [ __ ]
it's hard
it's hard it's like looking at somebody
who's been mistruded mistreated in a
relationship for years getting abused
and then when they say i don't trust the
[ __ ] you're like trust the [ __ ] be
beating you are you mad
so for me
i sit here upset i sit here bothered
because i'm watching the dialogue happen
everywhere right
our media has been so irresponsible with
how they've covered this whole thing the
scientists have gotten it wrong at so
many turns the politicians have enacted
policies that have killed so many people
and never not once did i ever hear
anybody take accountability for this
mistakes i've seen folks cover it up
i've seen folks admit that they were
lying i've seen folks just brush it
aside or do cover-ups but i've never
seen them take any accountability yet
we're supposed to
trust what they're saying
does that make sense to anybody at home
i could understand if you believe in the
facts i i'm taking it as well okay
i can understand why you trust all that
stuff
but you're telling me you cannot
understand why they don't
really you don't get it whatsoever and
the truth is people don't want to get it
people want to act like they know
because it makes them feel better
right because you get to sit there
sanctimoniously and snub your nose at
everyone like they're the idiots and
you're always on the right people have
very valid concerns whether people in
healthcare industries scientists
themselves or just everyday people
so you shouldn't talk about it why
shouldn't i talk about this you're
asking me to comply with what you want
my hesitancy the reasons why i'm unsure
should be voiced why because
unfortunately the media doesn't do it
for us
you know in my province you know what
they said we're not going to have a
debate in parliament when we pass the
vaccine passport why because we don't
want to spread misinformation are you
telling me that politicians can't get
together to discuss whether or not this
vaccine passport should be enacted
for fear
what are these elected officials can you
guys not get on the same page and have a
valid debate
what's going on the media is not allowed
to ask any tough questions to these
people either
they're not
what the [ __ ] is going on the people who
are supposed to keep the government in
check and ask these difficult questions
or collaborating with them so how am i
supposed to feel secure in all this to
feel like the process is being handled
well
when the media outlets who are supposed
to relay this information to us are not
doing a good job
again
i do think vaccines are the way forward
but i cannot sit here and act like you
guys are not [ __ ] giant hypocrites
for not acknowledging the very valid
reasons why these people are protesting
or against it today i just don't get
that you're all for black lives matter i
understand why they don't trust the
government then now you're like you
don't know come on
so let's have a better discussion that's
all i'm asking you don't have to agree
with them on the other side you don't
even have to go up there and say they're
valid you don't have to do
but don't label them as closed-minded
stupid individuals because we could do
the same to you i could say you're a
racist yes you're racist
for not acknowledging the real
oppression that black people have lived
and then expecting them to be complicit
in the system that has oppressed them i
could say that but i don't believe that
all of you are i could say that you guys
are just governed by your fear and your
[ __ ] sheep with the government but i
don't believe that
but you're fine with looking at the
other side and saying they're the idiots
this is where public discourse is today
and i don't care you know youtube do
rank this demonetize it is what it is it
is what it is but i've been so upset
just seeing people who i thought were
well-rounded people who are willing to
give the other side a chance and just
seeing how stupid some of these takes
are i'm not a scientist i can't read the
studies and figure it all out so i can't
tell you if it's efficacy somebody else
smarter than me should handle that
but to sit like it's just everyone
agrees and everyone should be implied
it's disappointing man it's
disappointing you know and the same
thing that led to trump is what's
leading to this situation right now
people marginalize the other side and
then just putting them in a box
carry on see how well that's going to
last you guys in the future but i
promise you if you want to fracture
society more than you can today it's by
doing stuff like that and that's my
thoughts i'mma take the vaccine i'm
never gonna be for the passport that's
it for me what do you think preach
but it is what it is i think you know
what i'll be honest with you i think
being online and just seeing all these
opinions is not good for me no that's
not that's why you disconnected it in
the first place i mean you know what
phil phil i'm not talking to phil philip
franco as if he's gonna watch this phil
um
the reason you
have an outlet
the reason you're doing what you're
doing right now
is because of and then because you're
doing great you're doing great you're
doing great
phil
the reason for that is because there is
a distress in the media
that's the whole reason you're doing
what you're doing
that's the whole reason why you're at
the position you are mind you
that's the whole reason we're at the
position that we are
because there's a whole distress in
normal media it's also kind of handsome
sure i'll give you that
because the dm's i'm sick of it
phil that's the reason why
so just for you to sit there and be like
no believe what these people are saying
you're still gonna eat
you're still gonna make your dough
because of this just
but now you want them you want us you
want them you want the people to believe
them i don't understand it
i'm not even saying that it's
intentional maybe you just thought you
didn't think this thing through which is
possible and you know they were all
humans you know what i mean but you
don't understand
the people that are anti-vaccine are
riding right now and are against it have
the same ammo are not the same people
but they have the same ammo as the black
lives matter people
you don't understand whatsoever why the
distrust
it's not a black and white thing but it
kind of is
it's not it's not even a black and white
thing but
you know
we have a problem with black man we
ain't cops
we do
but in the health system
doctors are the policemen of black women
yeah
that you're me
that was a black woman saying preach
[Music]
that was a black woman say yeah
but that's what it is in the health
system
a doctor is going to be
what a policeman is to a black man to a
black woman
and to black people in general
so you don't understand the distrust you
don't
you're disregarded at all
that's all
that's odd
it ain't even a right thing or a left
thing i have people from the right and i
got people from the left
that agree with that
but the leaning ones are the left though
i gotta admit you know why i say the
left because they claim to acknowledge
the suffering i know because there's
that's why i know because i don't know
hypocrisy i don't know this is yeah this
is barker i understand why you say left
yeah i understand i got that because the
lever like no you should yo they're the
first one to say like [ __ ] the
government and [ __ ] this and [ __ ] that
and then when it comes to this it's like
no not [ __ ] it i need it it's like i
kind of you expect indigenous
communities
indigenous communities to trust the
government no they can't trust
and no do you explain
what they do
native americans or natives everywhere
in the world they ain't gonna just why
would they why would they
give me one [ __ ] good reason why
would they
history bruv
come on now you know come on now the
place is right the places with the
highest levels of complete listen i just
want to say what all this is
illustrating is this is the failures of
the government when it comes to earning
the trust of their people and if you
don't think you have to work towards
that you don't have to work when you
just force people then you're going to
have this kind of friction it is
incumbent on you our elected officials
to prove to us that you actually have us
in your best interest to take
accountability when you [ __ ] up right
the same way if i committed a crime i
would be held accountable right by the
police officer in the law you guys
should be held accountable for the [ __ ]
ups that we uncover about you but you're
not right
when it comes to the scientists who make
all these mistakes and these promises
that they can't keep they should come
out and say this is why we were wrong
let us be transparent there was none of
that
earn the trust of the people and they
will reward you
you guys have no leadership yet you
expect people to follow you
how does that make sense
and i'm considered an anti-vaxxer even
though i want to get vaccinated i'm
gonna get vaccinated i'm gonna for even
saying you're being misguided you're
gonna stop people if me saying this on
youtube is what stops somebody from
going to get vaccinated then i'm sorry
the public outreach has been terrible
from the government to jump with why the
[ __ ] would a youtuber like me be the
differences in these people's lives you
should have done such a good job that
[ __ ] like me can't do nothing about it
but you haven't and i'm not even saying
anything crazy i'm saying
show better leadership
anti-vaxxer are you dumb
and that's the thing you can i have you
know what i'ma tell you i had to cover
it i had it bad
i had it you had it you bad i got it i
had it back bad
it's like i got hit by a truck
i got my two doses
but you questioning doesn't mean that
you're inherently anti-vaxxed
it doesn't mean that your anti it's just
that
you're either pro-choice or you're not
and i'm pro-choice you want to get that
vaccine i'm not going to judge you you
don't want to get the vaccine i
understand
that's it that's it i'm not going to put
you in the dugout
because oh you don't think like me
you're not open-minded it's funny how
money changes situation but it's funny
how tell them
you want people to be open-minded
but that rhetoric only comes out when
they don't think like you
that makes you close-minded boo-boo
boo-boo
yo i'm gonna give you another one
youtube and their whole black history
month i want to push black creativity
yeah no [ __ ] you want to push black
creators you like and that say what you
enjoy yes but when it comes to actually
talking about the suffering of black
people in a way that may not be
conducive to your platform you're not so
when all these black history months come
things come along and everyone's like oh
my god they're not they're not really
about it they're not really about it the
idea that you would flag someone for
talking about what happened in tuskegee
as a reason why hesitancy makes a lot of
sense the reason that you would take a
video that that blows my mind that's
literal world history it's like
someone's saying slavery and
jim crow makes me hesitant to trust the
government so i was like take it down
that's real that's generational so
youtube also determined needs a lot of
accountability in regards to how they
claim to be for these causes but you
find out behind closed door all right
you know what it's costing us a bit as
cash potentially there's some pressure
[ __ ] the [ __ ] don't just be about
black people when it's convenient don't
be about minorities when it's cool and
trendy right gay pride is a day but
guess what if you [ __ ] with gay people
the rest of the year it doesn't mean
[ __ ] gay pride is not a date it's a
whole last month is it it's a whole last
month see
see i don't even know that
that's how you know i don't go but
anyways i digress
you guys got the point i'm not even
going to edit this video you guys want
to get it raw it is what it is
hopefully you guys enjoyed the take
anything else you're giving it raw
pause
the big possibility i didn't have to say
it like that
say it like that
what i have to say like oh baby i like
it wrong
foreign
[Music]